hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous video you could
see
us hooking up our electronics so now we
have a fridge
so we can cool down ourselves we can
also now
drink cool water which is very
refreshing
big upgrade and we don't have to eat
soggy lattice anymore
so that's cool and this really is more
and more needed because the temperatures
are going up
due to summer so in this video we're
going to do something else to prepare
ours for the upcoming heat
which is we're going to clean uh bottom
part of the land where there's some
fresh water flowing
but at the moment is fully overgrown and
bushy so we cannot really access
it properly so we're gonna start
cleaning it up
and hopefully create a nice place where
we can take a dip
in a hot summer day
[Music]
so we have this water stream flowing on
our land and today we're gonna clean it
up
right there and this is the place at the
end of our big grass patch
around there and what is great is that
there's a shade from this big
old cork tree it's actually one of the
few trees that survived during the big
forest fire a few years ago
a good area to create a place to cool
down in summer
i mean it looks great from the drone
nice and fresh
but coming closer it actually looks like
this very overgrown
and right now you're actually not even
able to access the creek
just lots of bushes and thorns and dead
trees
but we're gonna clean it up and we have
our moms here to help out
my mom and krita's mom and these are the
tools we'll be using
time to get started
it's a little bit bushy here and we
start today on the project
and we are going to clean the bushy area
in
in order we can reach the greek and
can refresh ourselves when
the cool the warm days come
do you see potential in the water if you
clean
yeah but also this and this area this
area
in this area if you clean this area
[Music]
so there is a big that tree over here
and we will just cut it
you
nice
shoot
[Music]
[Music]
so
what not very hot so much sweat
are you hot a little bit the creek is
almost ready
for the two cool down yes
so we basically spent the morning
chopping dead trees and removing a lot
of bushes
at this point we have a spiky thorns up
till our
and but we're still making progress we
actually can now
access the creek which is very exciting
to touch the water
and we also saw a little bridge next to
it
which is great but first time for some
more important business
what's that in the box
croissant chocolate croissant
and orange juice fresh orange juice
can we take a swim in the afternoon yeah
sure i hope so
we have to we have to try yeah
after all these work we have to
celebrate it we have to celebrate with
great so we just did the more rough work
we've been chopping down some old trees
or some trees that could not hold
themselves
and now we have some shady places or
some places where we can walk without
the brumbles and now it's about
tidying it up
[Music]
so
[Music]
all around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fasting
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so it's time for a swim yes yoho
yeah it is cool
what do you think honey we did the good
work
we did a good job good job for our
children
yeah all those people in project camp
yeah
to cool down
and to to relax because the space is
more
open and with a little bit of shadow
and the water is really fresh
yes and clean and i hope you
enjoy it and what if you come next time
and it's like pushes everywhere again
i kill you
all right you know your mom
[Laughter]
so later that day as we finish the work
we put our tools back in the workspace
and now i wanted to start recording some
clips of the final result to you guys to
show
however the weather changed quite
rapidly
currently i have a lot of big kills
it was just 30 degrees and now we have
guys like this
killstones
very noisy it's another surprise for the
portuguese weather
did not see that coming
and a great tool to protect from pointy
hillstones
look at this avocado
so now we are next day back to normal
like nothing happened
but as you can see quite some plants got
damaged
uh so i hope they will recover we have
actually been speaking with some
neighbors and for them it was quite
catastrophic because they grow a lot of
their own food so they have land with a
lot of crops
and a lot of those got damaged with the
hillstones
so i guess they sort of need to bridge a
gap now that they have in their food
supply
for us less of a big deal they're all
young trees and it's more like a herbal
garden
so we have less to lose but i hope
everything recovers here we'll keep an
eye on it
i was also happy that the solar panels
didn't get damaged
because the recently installed and a
hillstone is
almost one of the most aggressive things
you can have on it but that all survived
so all good so yeah sun is shining again
weather is good so i'm gonna show you
our finished work from yesterday
so let me show you the results from
above you can now actually see the water
flowing
and the area around it is opened up
there was already a little bridge here
to access the other side
and with the stairs we can go down
so
[Music]
all right so we finally have a very cool
place to access
the very refreshing creek of this land
so the sounds here are
really cool where we can hear kind of a
waterfall
far away and also the flowing creek over
here
this big tree gives a good shade where
we can
sit under and also some stairs that we
can
access easily the creek and if we
try to make a dam maybe the water will
be a bit
uh higher and then we can have
a deeper bath in the creek
so this will be very very useful for
summer time
and we just have a long continuation
along the creek
to go i hope you enjoyed to see the
video
and if you want to support us you know
you go to support.com
you know you know because i don't
you go somewhere and
where do you go
i will put a link somewhere here
you go to that link if you want to
support us out
thank you very much for watching and see
you in the next video
and besides finishing the work i think
we might have also finished our moms
we finished with the work and we
finished with ourselves
and we are so tired
not me